font la rentrée cette année dans le
petit Robert l'édition 2023 les covidés
je vous épargne la définition évidemment
vous le savez personne atteinte du covid
qui peuvent aussi souffrir
ils disent
on va vérifier ça si c'est bien si c'est
bien la bonne définition parce que vous
savez donc ce que c'est qu'une
Goo
alors je vous donne la définition nom
féminin issus d'une langue d'Afrique de
l'Ouest le bambara qui signifie une
jeune fille une petite amie c'est très
courant en Afrique francophone
à la maison
oh la vache ce sont des scènes qu'on a
tous vu et qui suscitent la gênance
alors là j'ai dans le service
entre nous je n'ai jamais bien compris
l'emploi de ce mot puisque il y a un
synonyme en français qui s'appelle gêne
qui en plus qui est plus
cools
qui me plaisent bah il y en a pas
beaucoup et pour une raison j'explique
pas du tout celui-là me plaît donc oui
j'aimerais bien ton choix je vais pas
raconter des
carabistouilles comme on dit la mode
j'ai envie de faire une story pour
expliquer que j'ai les fuites urinaires
à 31 ans et que
tu vas pas
quelque chose parce que je comprends pas
j'ai fait la rééducation du périnée
dans le monde virtuel il faut se méfier
des brouteurs donc les brouteurs ça
vient d'un usage africain et ce sont des
gens qui qui ne font qu'à abrouter de
l'herbe gratuitement et qui n'appartient
pas donc ce sont des escrocs qui piègent
leurs victimes sur Internet qui peuvent
piéger
ça aussi ça fait son truc et sur de toi
tu es sûr mais oui quand j'ai mes règles
et que je fais du trampoing
ou pas
tu dépasses les mites j'ai une famille
je ne supporte pas les tatouages que
j'avais pas vu c'est les photos
on s'est tout dit moi pour moi ça me
suffit je vous souhaite à tous les deux
une belle vie c'est ce qui se fait je
pense que ce serait compliqué
un peu pour l'instant je suis pas dans
le la compassion c'est 350 fois la
tout de suite jamais
tu sais qu'entre ce système de peur on
se parle beaucoup et on sait tous dit
jamais tu t'assois avec lui tu te
racontes ces histoires et il a 14
spectacles et moi j'ai plus
l'expérimenter ça avec toi
c'est une petite petite faiblesse pour
pour les madeleines dans le film vous
avez la tellement vous régaler on dirait
Louis de Funès qui va dans le frigo
oui c'est vrai j'étais incroyable c'est
Madeleine
de ma gueule ou quoi
exactement
[Rires]
j'adore
et que quelqu'un prend un risotto c'est
un con en général
j'ai un carnet j'incarnerais
c'est toujours dégueulasse c'est
toujours des tocards j'ai l'impression
de mettre un bombe lacrymogène dans la
tronche
ça m'est arrivé ça tient je me suis
trompé je fais de l'asthme j'avais une
bombe un crimogène dans ma poche
et une ventoline
j'ai confondu
la situation que ça
[Applaudissements]
nous on t'a pris quelques têtes pourquoi
tu es là
il n'y a rien à comprendre on t'a choisi
à des je comprends pas je fais rien
toute ma vie et là c'est bon je ne
comprends pas pourquoi j'ai cette chance
et
donc voilà tout ça qu'on pose une école
une époque assez formidable qui donne
envie de se blottir ce dans sa couette
ou sur son canapé et qui donne envie de
filer ça vient de l'anglais tout chill
c'est à dire prendre du bon temps à ne
rien faire exemple
qu'il est devant une série voilà donc
depuis ce weekend on peut suivre on peut
les suivre toute la journée et
effectivement il ne pense plus du tout
aux caméras
[Musique]